at the start of the movie a spoiled rich
kid named Grisha is returning from a
club when he notices his car being towed
away enraged he starts running after the
tow truck while swearing at the driver
unfortunately he gets into an accident
and passes out later he is woken up in a
stable by a man named artium who is
dressed in primitive clothing he keeps
on telling Grisha to take the horse to
the Lord Grisha is also dressed in
similar clothes and puzzled he tries to
make sense of the situation soon a man
named avdi shows up and drags Grisha
outside before thrashing him for not
saddling the horse as ordered by the
Lord after a while the Lord comes out
and asks him why he hasn't readied the
horse thinking it's a joke Grisha tries
to be rude but gets severely whipped
despite this the Lord decides to give
Grisha another chance to bring at the
horse but the arrogant prick threatens
them with his dad's power and tries to
run away thinking everything is just a
prank surely artium cusher is around the
corner in a truck however the
surrounding reality is too real and the
people are too convincing Grisha
eventually realizes that he is a
disenfranchised surf in a small village
in the Russian Empire the year is 1860
and it is summertime this was six months
before the abolition of serfdom surfs
are the poorest of the peasant class and
are a type of slave Lord Zone the serfs
who live on their lands and in exchange
the poor people are made to grow crops
day and night Grisha is eventually
caught by the Lord's men and he is
dragged away to be hanged for trying to
escape even in a precarious situation as
such he arrogantly demands to see a
lawyer until he sees another peasant
hanging dead from a rope now his
demeanor totally changes and he begs for
forgiveness Grisha who has been pampered
all of his life is definitely not used
to being threatened by others hence he
starts remembering his past life Grisha
is a 27 year old spoiled son of a
Russian billionaire Pavel he is Brash
arrogant and rude to everyone he meets
the movie then rewinds to a few days
back where Grisha is in a club trying to
hit on a beautiful girl named anfisa
however she shows attitude and makes fun
of his cliche way of hitting on her
challenged Grisha walks over to a club
employee building a champagne Tower and
takes out two glasses from the bottom
destroying the structure and creating a
scene what a whiny [ __ ] he then offers
anfisa one champagne glass saying no
other girl has the same drink as hers
this finally impresses the girl and the
two have drinks later in his fancy car
Grisha demands oral coitus from her and
when anfisa refuses he kicks her out and
heads back home on his way he drives
beyond the speed limit prompting a
police car to show up and pull him over
surprisingly the spoiled brat isn't
afraid of the law and initially tries to
escape but when the police officer
threatens to use weapons he is forced to
stop Grisha has been used to bribing the
police and getting out of tough
situations even this time he tries the
same technique but to his surprise the
newly transferred officer rejects the
money instead he climbs on the hood of
the vehicle to stop it however Grisha
could care less and he continues to
speed despite the officer ordering him
to stop ultimately they meet with an
accident and the police officer is
critically injured Grisha is taken into
custody and his father arrives at the
police station the station Chief is
pavel's friend and he reminds some of
the several laws that Grisha has broken
this month alone the chief also tells
him that it is the last time he is
helping him because Grisha has crossed
all limits the spoiled brat has severely
injured a police officer breaking his
ribs and pelvic bones but despite all of
this Grisha seems to have no sense of
guilt or remorse it finally begins to
Dawn on Pavel that Grisha will continue
to be more and more Reckless and
dangerous in faith that his Rich father
will rescue him from all sorts of
punishments after bailing him out Havel
orders Grisha to get his life together
threatening to block all his credit
cards however Grisha is not afraid of
his father's threats and instead he
taunts Pavel for being a money-hungry
Maniac before leaving he also tells his
father to focus on his competitors as
they might soon steal his business fed
up with his son's rude and Reckless
Behavior Pavel begins to look for a way
to change Grisha for the better he goes
over to meet his TV producer and friend
with benefits Anastasia she immediately
suggests that he meet her former
business client Lev Arnold an eccentric
psychologist Anastasia aka Anna explains
that while arnaldovich may have unusual
methods that may seem cruel and shocking
he almost always gives a guaranteed
result Pavel is skeptical about the plan
but since he has no other options and he
decides to give it a go shortly after
when the two go over to the
psychologist's creepy workspace Pavel is
given the shock of his life when he
walks into arnoldovic hanging from a
rope surprisingly everything is just an
illusion it turns out that arnaldovich
primarily builds elaborate sets for TV
and film companies he also employs his
talent to help individual clients by
creating realistic but false scenarios
he explains that he is currently working
on a project where his client wants to
fake hang himself to check his wife's
loyalty Anna explains pavel's problem to
arnoldovic but before the latter could
come up with something Pavel begins to
have doubts about The Eccentric man's
ways fortunately Anna convinces him to
at least hear the plan the scene then
cuts to Grisha coming out of a club he
notices his car being towed and starts
running after the tow truck swearing at
the dry driver unfortunately in the
process he runs into what seems like an
accident and passes out after this the
movie is taken to the present where
Grisha is about to be hanged but
fortunately for him aglia the daughter
of the Lord shows up aglia is a kind and
sensitive girl and she orders the Lord's
right-hand man avdi and her brother
Alexi to stop the execution however they
immediately refuse soon the commotion
attracts the attention of the Lord
himself it turns out that it is a
Goliath's birthday today and she pleads
with her father to stop the execution as
a birthday gift the Lord who loves his
daughter a lot grants her wish much to
everyone's annoyance on the other hand
Grisha is still processing everything
and he can't bring himself to thank
aglia for saving his life in the sky a
vulture who was eager to Feast on
gracious flesh flies away in sadness to
a wind turbine in the distance
surprisingly it is revealed that the
bird is actually a drone and the entire
19th Century Village turns out to be a
skillful production of Anastasia and the
psychologist arnautovich carried out
with pavel's money moreover the accident
that Grisha met with was arranged by his
father Pavel as well the goal of the
project is to completely change greesh's
view of the world around him and himself
the team is watching the spoiled brats
every move in the new environment from
their mission control inside the faux
wind turbine wow Ashton Kutcher might
actually be hanging out here the project
is not a perfect Recreation of 1860s
Russia but because Grisha is too
ignorant of basic Russian history he
fails to notice the many anachronisms
around him when the actors aren't
working they are allowed to come to the
mission control and refresh themselves
meanwhile trying to reason logically
Grisha still vehemently denies the
possibility of falling into the past but
then gradually comes to terms with the
position of a serf over the course of
the next few days he is made to work in
the stable with very little sleep or
resting time he is served with barely
edible vegetarian food and is forced to
defecate out in the open jokes on them
pooping in public is a fetish for the
Russian Uber Rich one day Grisha comes
across aglia Crying by herself he
Comforts her and as the two start
chatting she reveals that her father is
4 forcing her to marry an older and Rich
landowner however Grisha doesn't
sympathize with her as he believes that
a Golia marrying someone richer than her
father is an ideal situation for her
future he says that after her husband
dies she can have all the money for
herself it turns out that this was the
scriptwriter's plan for Grisha to begin
an affair with aglia developing into a
surf eloping with a lady and a complete
reassessment of Life attitudes sadly the
plan fails miserably fed up with eating
inedible food one day Grisha steals one
of the Lord's chickens with the help of
artium he finds a saucepan to prepare
chicken soup and uses the feathers to
make himself a nice and comfortable
pillow but sadly he doesn't share the
chicken soup with artium once again
leaving the scriptwriters frustrated
later when avdy notices the chicken
missing he rounds up all the Surfs and
demands the thief come forward
threatening to punish a random surf
otherwise expectedly Grisha doesn't
admit to stealing the chicken and as a
result avdy chooses to punish the
innocent artium however Grisha
shamelessly watches as artium is dragged
away to be punished meanwhile the lack
of progress in Greece's attitude makes
Pavel increasingly impatient and
Restless to make his mood worse he also
learns that arnoldovic is not Anna's
former client but her former husband
this Revelation takes the billionaire
aback as he had started to develop
feelings for Anna he confronts her about
it but she replies that she's not
obligated to share intimate details
about herself as they are just friends
with benefits later RTM confronts Grisha
for not confessing to his crime and
letting him take the fall however the
remorseless Grisha replies that he
doesn't care and that it was avdi who
chose to punish him as the two are
talking Grisha notices a village girl
Liza getting off of a horse surprisingly
while getting down she exposes her
modern Victoria's Secret panties Grisha
initially cracks a joke until it Dawns
on him that he just saw a modern panty
in the 18th century Village smelling a
rat he tackles her to the ground and
tries to look up her skirt but before he
can do so our team quickly pulls him off
of her despite this the resilient Grisha
still manages to look up her skirt and
notices that she's not wearing any
underwear it's then revealed that Liza
craftily removed her red panties before
Grisha could get to them after the
incident back in the control room Pavel
has had enough and he decides to shut
down the project as he's not seeing any
change in his son's Behavior Anna and
arnaldovich try to convince him against
pulling the plug but without success
meanwhile seeing the reaction of those
around him Grisha suddenly realizes that
he's gone too far and for the first time
in his life he returns to the person he
offended to ask for forgiveness this
amazes Pavel and he agrees to continue
the project give everyone a pair of
those panties says Pavel ever since then
Grisha proceeds to make a genuine
connection with Liza arnaldovich
proposes to change the scenario and make
her the object of grisha's Love Liza
despises the spoiled brat but she
nevertheless agrees to help him improve
along the way Grisha gradually changes
his views on life and himself he
regularly observes the Lord's cruel and
arrogant son of Lexi and starts
despising his own past here it is
revealed that the actor playing Alexi is
Liza's real-life boyfriend Anton
meanwhile the actress playing a golia's
role begins to get jealous of Liza after
the latter replaces her as the lead
actress of the project therefore she
convinces Anton that Liza is planning to
start an affair with Grisha one thing
leads to another and the two begin to
have intercourse but unfortunately for
them they are spotted by Liza and Grisha
while Liza is distraught that her
boyfriend cheated on her Grisha simply
believes that aglia and her brother
Alexi are having an incestuous affair
that night Liza is very upset so to
cheer her up Grisha decorates the stable
with candlelights and also cooks are a
wonderful dinner the gesture makes Liza
really happy shortly after they head
outdoors and sleep in the Open Sky while
stargazing Grisha expresses his feelings
to Liza and surprisingly the two make
out on the other hand a furious
arnoldovic removes both aglia and Alexi
from their roles in Revenge Paulina the
actors playing the role of aglia reveals
the project to the world she alleges
that a man is being tortured soon police
begin to investigate the project with
the help of Polina now with time running
out arnaldovich and the writers make an
emergency he planned to change Greece's
attitude once and for all they plan for
the golden horde aka the Mongols to
invade the 19th century Russia in
reality golden horde was an Empire which
declined in the 1500s however Grisha
doesn't notice the anachronism soon the
Mongols arrive and kidnap Liza but
instead of saving her Grisha reverts to
his selfish cowardly ways and runs away
seemingly dooming the project however
when he gets a bit far he realizes that
he has always run away from problems and
abandoned his loved ones hence with
renewed motivation he returns to the
scene bravely fights off the Invaders
and rescues Liza the two then ride away
on a horse just before the police arrive
and raid the sad fortunately since
Grisha has already left and all the
other people are actors they simply
assume the project to be a historical
film set and leave elsewhere Grisha
rides his horse for several minutes
until he reaches a gas station has
expected he has taken aback by the
modern world but before he can make
sense of the situation a set member
shoots him with a tranquilizer knocking
him out upon waking up he is told that
he fell into a coma for three months and
that all his imaginations were mere
hallucinations while his character
development remains Grisha realizes that
Liza was never real as a result he falls
into a depression one day he meets
Paulina and Anton the actors who played
the roles of aglia and Alexi
respectively at a club seeing his
miserable State the actors take pity on
him and to reveal everything hearing
this Grisha gets excited and immediately
starts searching for Liza he eventually
finds her in a stable and the two have a
romantic reunion on the other hand Pavel
expresses his feelings to Anna and the
two get married the movie then closes
with another oligarch son being dragged
into the village and being tricked into
believing he has fallen into feudal
Russia this time Grisha watches on as
part of the Project's team the moral of
today's story is that if you want to fix
a psychopath just Gaslight them
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching